- I have something to tell you.
I've been wanting to tell
you this for a long time,
but I was scared,
very scared about how you'd react, so...
God, why is it so hard to say this?
Oh yeah, I'm gay.
Super gay.
("Home Embrace" by Warner /
Chappell Production Music)
I guess I've always been
more into girls than usual.
But it's just still really
weird for me to say that I'm,
you know.
Gay, gay, gay.
I am so gay.
No, I don't have a girlfriend.
Can't even imagine having one.
It makes me nervous to even
think about kissing a girl.
I've (bleep) Tanya, I've (bleep) Lindsay,
I've (bleep) Lindsay's ex-girlfriend,
I've (bleep) Shirley's
current girlfriend, drama!
Mom and dad can never know, okay?
My mom tried to set me up
with her neighbor's daughter.
My dad's still not talking
to me, but whatever.
This is who I am.
He'll get over it eventually.
I'll never be one of those girls
who turns into a stereotypical lesbian.
Did I get IPA on my favorite flannel?
Hold my beannie.
I can't believe I'm gay.
I can't even imagine being straight.
You know what?
I feel relieved.
Like a wieght's been lifted.
I mean, it took some time,
but now my life is pretty great.
I'm happy I came out.
("Home Embrace" by Warner /
Chappell Production Music)
I just feel like, I'm gay, you're welcome.